so we spoke at length at Comic Con so
we're gonna have a little fun today
we're gonna play a game of would you
rather and it's all movie related making
in general so the first one is would you
rather get as many takes as you like or
have the pressure to nail it in one oh
man I'm gonna have the pressure to nail
it in one do you mean like the pilots
are named in one I guess super pilots
are just getting the first two sometimes
the pressure is there you have a whole
day to get a shot yeah I think I good
for that yeah yeah because otherwise
you're just gonna exhaust everyone if
you have like 200 takes understandable
would you rather work with an actor who
prepares too much or not enough
I mean you've he's always got to be too
much how was it working with the team on
this was everyone's super yeah I mean
just good yeah I think you see these
things and people say oh all these nice
things about each other anything yeah
what really but genuinely pacer and
Damien and and Jonas he played Irene
Burke and Frenchie were just like such
an honor and dream to work with and they
were so prepared so you know I talked
them through everything we went to
storyboards and scripts and characters
and created backstories and then it was
just pleasurable when she was such a
nice surprise
yeah I just I guess I was so so focused
on the nine of the promos that far have
been very focused on on sister Irene and
secret weapon they don't that yeah yeah
it was a nice a nice light touch to the
movie - appreciate it would you rather
have an actor get in the headspace
themselves for a scare or would you
rather take it into your own hands
and I created a surprise scare while
shooting I think it genuinely a little
bit of both and I think both of us
prefer that anyway because you you know
the actor has to go and do a lot of the
work themselves because a lot of the
time they're obviously acting with
nothing there but to help that I like to
you know do what I can
whether it's having something physical
practical you know sometimes if we
didn't have the demon nun but we would
have some nun that we could place in
shot you know as an example there was a
sequence when Tyson and Ingrid were
having to hide from this demonic
presence and I got I had a microphone
and I just felt the easiest way to
actually orchestrate the timing was just
to sort of do some demonic heavy
breathing really so I would be sort of
good it sounds like what these hallways
sound like all the time we've been here
would you rather would you rather work
with ten angry pas or one angry reactor
I don't fire people but you could fire
PA is more than the lead actor so go
with ten angry bees get rid of them
we'll find a nice one and gallon with a
good actor would you rather work on a
set with no food or no caffeine I don't
drink coffee so I've done that I
definitely have no caffeine except that
everyone else on a crew be so pissed off
okay would you rather work with a CG
creature or real animal that's an
interesting one I mean I mind I was
about to say all real all the time but
there's certain things you just can't
work with real and so again as much as
possible I would work with a real animal
or a real person or a prize could affect
and then use CG to enhance that with
this same be true of your demonic none
here because we do know that there is
there
someone that that is a real thing that
was physically there but yeah you know I
guess there is a scenario where you
could have the real thing blended with
digital there is but I mean I think
genuinely as human beings we are afraid
of things which feel real and you see
G's got so good
but it's so much harder to create
genuine the photo real unnerving
creations than it is to have stuff in
camera would you rather work non-stop
and make all the movies you want or
would you rather have to wait a really
long time to make that one passion
project the artist in me is option two
and the person who wants to make and get
a good experience and then keep looking
rolling is option one so I'd put them
both together and keep making movies
until I make the dream as well